i've heard you compare
stagnation of the scientific community
to technology or or to
corporate uh commercial technology
because you know companies like spacex
for example which
obviously are funded and they generate a
profit
compared to um science and
the communities that you're involved in
can you speak a little bit to that
yeah so one would expect the academic
world
to take more risks than the commercial
world because companies are
mainly focused on making a profit
whereas in academia
there is this concept of tenure where
the professor
has a secure job and the purpose of that
was that once you get to that phase
uh you can explore blue sky research and
take risks and
you know allow yourself to be wrong if
it doesn't
end up the way you wanted
unfortunately most of my colleagues in
academia do not take risks because
they want to get honors and awards and
they want to maintain an image of
someone that doesn't make mistakes and
they build echo chambers that repeat
their
voice makes it making it louder so that
their reputation is improved but at the
same time they don't innovate
much because innovation implies
taking risks and being wrong sometimes
and at the same time in the commercial
sector you find companies
as you mentioned like spacex or google
or
many others that that have groups of
people that are thinking
uh that are taking risks and and
checking ideas out of the box and
the reason they do that is because they
recognize that the next major discovery
then
that will make them a big profit would
come in
unexpected directions so they're taking
risks because even though some of the
directions fail
if one of them ends up being real uh
it would compensate for all the losses
associated with the failed directions
and
if companies recognize the value of that
academia should have recognized it much
more and
i'm you know it's quite unfortunate that
there is not as much innovation
in academy as it should as there should
be and
uh that's why um i'm trying to promote
uh an open mind uh in the context that
we discussed before
of searching for technological
signatures but more generally
i think it's extremely important for
example for
federal grants to be given also to
people that
have risky propositions people that
consider
ideas out of the box nasa for example
very often funds
projects that can declare ahead of time
what they will discover what they will
find and that's contradictory to the
nature of
discovery very often you discover things
that you haven't expected you cannot
tell in advance to the funder what you
will find
or else what you're doing is very boring
so
i think the funding agencies should also
allocate
some fraction of their funding to risky
propositions to out-of-the-box thinking
and
allow for that it all comes together in
a culture where
innovation and risk-taking is
appreciated
yeah it almost doesn't make sense it
almost seems like
somebody like elon musk would have way
more to lose by
venturing outside the box than uh then a
researcher or
or a scientist would it seems like i
agree
i completely agree but it's human nature
to
uh that drives people in academia
towards
uh less being less innovative less
risk-taking because this way they can
maintain an image
that makes no you know of someone
reputable so that they
get honors and awards and by the way one
way to not
not make mistakes is not to put skin in
the game
so not to be engaged in predictions that
can be
tested experimentally and proven wrong
and that's why you find
this culture of people that work on
subjects that are sort of esoteric
have no connection to reality and cannot
be tested experimentally because
that's much more attractive you can just
demonstrate that you're smart
and never be proven wrong isn't that the
point of science to be proven wrong
yes i would argue that and that's what i
argue yes
and that's what i practice i don't just
preach but
it's not easy to change the culture and
i think it should change
and i hope it will change and my book
discusses that
as one of the most important messages of
the book so i i very much encourage
people to have a look in it
and you talk about einstein as well yeah
i mean
einstein in the last decade of his
career when he was the most experienced
uh and obviously he was the leading
scientist of his generation
uh made three mistakes and
these were major mistakes that we now
know are
completely wrong based on experiments
you know we detected gravitational waves
and he claimed they don't exist we
detected black holes
he claimed they don't exist and we also
detected
spooky action at a distance in quantum
mechanics and he claimed it doesn't
exist and
uh but that's part of being at the
frontier you never know in advance
you know what is the right direction and
even if you are the smartest person
around like einstein was
you make mistakes and that should be
tolerated because if you look at
einstein
you know he also made important
breakthroughs at the same time or or
before that time
and so the other thing is
his generation was putting skin in the
game you know he was making predictions
and they were tested the current
generation
wants to always be valued as
smart without putting any skin in the
game
so they you know a lot of physicists
theoretical physicists
are doing intellectual gymnastics
they're using sophisticated mathematics
and
that serves the role of demonstrating
their smart but
it doesn't necessarily describe nature
do you think some of the reason that
you're getting a lot of backlash
is because people are are
threatened by you coming out and talking
about this maybe they see avi getting
all this attention and talking about
this but they've never gotten this this
amount of attention from anyone about
any of their ideas
well as one aspect of that is jealousy
of course for that intention but
another one is because i address uh
my main message is that we should be
modest that science is a learning
experience and that making mistakes
is okay that's part of the scientific
process you know
we should be just like kids trying to
understand the world and willing to
not be so attached to our egos so i'm
trying to remove
that connection between the ego of a
scientist
and the profession you know we are
trying to understand nature we should
engage in a dialogue with experiments
we should not consider it as an
evaluation of our abilities
it's not about us it's about
understanding nature
and it's a dialogue with experiments and
we just have to start from a point of
modesty
you know and that modesty is
communicated to us by looking at the
universe you know
we are so small we are so shortly how
can anyone be arrogant okay that makes
no sense to me
how can anyone be racist you know that
also makes no sense to me because
just based on the color of his skin you
decide what the person is
i mean that's completely ridiculous so
people have this tendency of wanting to
feel
superior to other people either by
demonstrating that they're smart
or by demonstrating that their dna may
be superior to others
all kinds of ways of demonstrating
superiority and it all
drives it all stems from their ego
and what i say is just leave that aside
that causes the worst
in human nature you know all of the wars
all of the
the worst things that happened in human
history were driven by ego
we should try to push it aside be as
modest as possible which is what the
universe is telling us
stay modest you are not at the center of
anything and
we might be rapid we might not be the
smartest kid on the block
i'm trying to convey this message and
the pushback is in part
because people are too attached to their
ego it bothers them
takes them out of their comfort zone
they want to feel as if they are
respected smart never make mistakes
never
have to revise their view of the
universe just like the philosophers
during the days of galileo they didn't
want to look through the telescope
because they were happy believing that
they're at the center of the universe
they were comfortable where they were
exactly sort of like my daughters
saying we don't want to go to a
kindergarten
you know at home if you have a small
enough environment at home
we feel as if we are you know the
smartest kid
there is nobody like us we feel great
that's our comfort zone we will never go
out
and you know that's sort of the tendency
not
to explore because then you you feel
proud of yourself
you can be arrogant if you limit your
view to a small environment
but it's it's it goes against the
fundamentals of science because
i think staying comfortable inhibits
growth exactly
that's my point right exactly and then
and that's why i have this battle and
by the way i'm getting a huge response
from the public
a lot of emails also from people in
academia that feel the same
mostly young people because young people
are not attached
as much to their ego and
i'm hopeful for the future you know i i
do not care how many likes i have on
twitter
i just am focused you know just like
basketball coaches
advice their team players
keep your eyes on the ball not on the
audience and that's what i'm trying to
[Laughter]
do